c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
tout va bien ça y est alors je vous
explique ce qui se passe quelqu'un vient
de prendre mon oreillette en otage et
ils savent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est empreint de faire un personnage
que je n'arrive pas identifié de
monsieur qui parlent tout doucement et
il est en train de me donner des
consignes
[Rires]
et qu'ils allaient à venlo la regarder
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'on peut lui être un peu trop
qu'on en produit tous parce que c'est un
personnage exceptionnel qu'il était en
train de me faire j'aime je t'aime bien
je pense alors que ce sketch a démarré
j'aime bien c'est le fils de chantal
ladesou je suis arrivé les chroniqueurs
sont arrivés et on a croisé cyril depuis
17h45 qui le connaît comme thierry
moreau je t'aime beaucoup
eric je t'aime beaucoup hiver de bien
jaunir mais je pressais marc tu pense
qu'il est beaucoup plus que ça le pire
[Musique]